[Musique]
combien tu as bad dans la couenne de 16
je crois ce serait bien tu vois un
médecin un pied cadre c'est bien toi tu
vois un médecin un de ces quatre j'ai
pas des balles dans le corps mais ça
c'est parce que j'étais toujours
couverts étaient au courant pour
l'évasion s'était bonnie & clyde madame
le gouverneur il faut que ça cesse ils
ont commis de nombreux vols à main armée
et des meurtres de sang froid
un commentaire sur l'évasion nous allons
capturer bonnie & clyde écrivait cette
phrase et soulignait la 2 fois je ne
connais qu'un homme capable de les
arrêter
je vais revenir il ya de la place pour
moi t'es même pas équipés
nantes est allé monte on est en 1934 ce
sont des gangsters avec des
mitraillettes et vous voulez que des
cobayes traque bonnie & clyde des texas
rangers ce bulletin spécial la police
dans le missouri vient de signaler une
terrible fusillade entre les gangsters
bonnie & clyde et des représentants de
l'ordre
give me forme de feu c'est une opération
très organisés barrage surveillance
aérienne maintenant vous êtes à la
retraite cowboys en quoi est en train de
transformer le monde à une époque il
fallait du talent pour être publiés
alors que maintenant suffit tuer des
gens
la retourner vers elle avec son pied
pour qu'ils comprennent bien ce qui
allait se passer salut série c'est allé
trop loin
on va les descendre s'ajoute une
excellente idée
[Musique]
qui êtes vous j'imagine qu'on est les
méchants
n'a pas choisi le bon endroit par ici
klein c'est un roi
clyde et est un roi mais moi je suis un
texas ranger trou du cul